[Musique]
salut les mecs c'est lui nous sommes
salut tout le monde donc ça allait bien
mieux on est dégueu dingue comme un
shopping c'est à nous maintenant ok on
fait krari rhin mois ses chars marie
deuxième du nom auquel vous êtes juste à
côté de la maison pas loin du 7 5 007
tiennent un mec hyper des fonds se
marier du foot quoi lui alors moi c'est
james ludo on est deux frères à ça comme
ça et aujourd'hui on est là pour parler
de gros sous là parce qu'on a un objet à
vous présenter d'ankara shopping
incroyable ya exposé mokpo smokehouse
moque
ah si possible il est le co le pack
week-end découverte chez charles marie
james udo et lil wayne
yes à ces personnes vous propose un
séjour dans nos propriétés parisiennes
et attendait bien posé vous bien rester
calmes ont là une [ __ ] de fontaine au
tarama mec
allez allez à temps ne dévoile pas tout
jeune studio on est déjà dans le turf
sûrs nous on adore parler là vers langue
donc programme hyper serré samedi matin
et avoue chercher en hélicoptère chez
vous on vous ramène dans notre propriété
pour un premier atelier le petit d'âge
la collation préparée par le chef de top
chef de la saison de ventre choix et
pour l'apéro les amis qu'est ce qu'on a
fait ben c'est simple on a acheté
l'ancien chef cuisine de kadhafi mais
genre juste pour le houmous à ce que je
veux ou mousse et à tomber 21 janv le
mou c'est dingue genre le mec et des
termes consignes d'amérique
ensuite ces soirées ciné mais attention
pas n'importe quel film le coeur des
hommes
jouer en live par les comédiens dans le
salon vous verrez un jean pierre
darroussin est adorable
allez allez à 23 heures ce sera la
chatte à master carreau puis le
lendemain matin petit déj avec un
accompagnement d'un groupe en live les
trois cafés gourmands featuring the week
end vous avez bien entendu à l'e3 café
gourmand l'avouer
bonjour gastambide il ya mille quoi
les avis et c'est cette possibilité
d'entrer cette moto certifier les
cristaux swarovski papa aime pas du tout
qu'on me raconte mais en vrai soir ou ce
qui fait des petites motos exactement
way et tout ça c'est inclus dans le
fameux pack week-end découverte chez
charles marie est james ludovia ça
mouline
ok ça mouline et tout ça les amis c'est
pour la modique somme de 6000 750 euros
quand vous offre ouais ouais ouais parce
que franchement on se fait chier ouais
je sais bien qu'il ya un peu d'écart à
kilinochchi moi c'est un peu la herse la
banque voit les werc les amis donc
retrouvez nous sur caire à shopping
point fr pour ce pack découverte a très
vite ça commence à s'éteindre à caméra
donc je vais caché objectifs avec un
truc qui sert à rien la roche souffre la
black card
c'est toi qui aura plein de caméras
corse il vient d'acheter un nouveau char
jack muslin aiba il permet en bo1
[Musique]